pendant près de 20 ans le père bernard
prénat du diocèse de lyon aurait agressé
sexuellement entre 70 et 100 scouts âgés
de 8 à 12 ans le réalisateur françois
ozon a décidé de faire un film inspiré
de l'histoire vécue par les victimes du
pédophile
samedi après-midi maintenant quelles
photos de la paroisse c'est une fiction
basée sur des faits réels
tout ce que je raconte dans le film sur
les prêtres l'évêque sur le silence qui
a eu lieu au sein du diocèse de lyon
était déjà connu de toute la presse
française avait déjà été racontée
je n'invente rien des gosses le film
grâce à dieu illustre bien la souffrance
vécue par les victimes et la difficulté
pour elle de briser le silence
ces hommes meurtris se doivent se battre
contre l'église et parfois contre leurs
proches vérité c'est tu nous emmerdes
letton est temps de curé
moi ce qui m'intéressait c'était de
montrer qu'il y avait une forme de
double peine c'est à dire que d'abord
ses hommes ont été abusés quand il était
enfant donc une première souffrance et à
partir du moment où il décide de parler
il y a encore des répercussions très
forte autour d'eux c'est très violent
d'oser parler parce que ça déstabilise
tout leur entourage et grâce à dieu tous
ces faits sont prescrits
le film met aussi en scène le cardinal
du diocèse de lyon fait les barbarins
qui dans cette affaire a été jugée
coupable de non dénonciation d'agression
sexuelle il a fait appel du verdict
et cette semaine le pape a refusé sa
démission enfin moi ce que j'attends
c'est une sanction de l'église à son
encontre
il avait une occasion en or le pape de
dire effectivement le cardinal barbarin
est un symbole du silence de l'omerta
qui a eu lieu au sein du diocèse de lyon
pendant plusieurs années donc j'accepte
sa démission
il ne l'a pas fait en un jour en sortant
du catéchisme je tenais
que près la maison bras celle du grand
prix du jury au festival du film de
berlin
grâce à dieu a eu un énorme impact en
france où il a été vu par huit cent
mille personnes
mon film a eu un impact fort en france
parce que beaucoup de catholiques s'en
sont emparés pour dire ça y est
maintenant il faut changer les choses il
faut que ça bouge
quoi tu peux nous sommes 20 cette
histoire est loin d'être terminée le
père bernard prénat dont il est question
dans ce grand film devrait subir un
procès d'ici la fin de l'année ici louis
philippe ouimet radio-canada mourir